nos han dado el valor de hdx y algunos
valores de x sabemos lo siguiente
jaime dice que ya que h de 7 - h de 3
entre 7 menos 3 es igual a 1 esta es la
tasa de cambio promedio entre x 3 y x 7
debe existir un número c en el intervalo
cerrado de 3 a 7 para el cual la
derivada de h en ese valor se es igual a
1 lo que jaime trata de hacer es aplicar
el teorema del valor medio el cual nos
dice que estamos entre dos valores
digamos que aquí tenemos a y aquí
tenemos b y la función se ve así y si se
cumplen las condiciones para este
teorema existe un valor se entre a y b
donde la derivada de c será igual a la
tasa de cambio promedio entre a y b la
tasa de cambio promedio será la
pendiente de la recta secante que pasa
por a y b al ver lo que dibuje parece
que hay varios puntos que cumplen con
esto que tienen la pendiente de su recta
tangente igual a la de esta otra recta
tenemos este punto y también tenemos
este otro punto esto es lo que afirma el
teorema del valor medio si se cumplen
las condiciones tendremos al menos un
valor ce cuya derivada en ese punto será
igual a la tasa de cambio promedio del
primer extremo al último extremo cuáles
son las condiciones que deben cumplirse
para que se pueda aplicar el teorema del
valor medio lo hemos visto en varios
vídeos una forma de pensar en ello es
que si nos fijamos en el intervalo
cerrado de 3 a 7 una condición es que
tiene que ser diferenciable en el
intervalo abierto de 3 a 7 es el
intervalo sin incluir los puntos
extremos y tiene que ser continua en el
intervalo cerrado de 3 a 7 incluyendo
los extremos algo interesante que
mencionamos antes es que la diferencia
habilidad implica continuidad si algo es
diferenciable en el intervalo abierto
también será continuo en el intervalo
abierto por lo que la segunda condición
hace explícito que también tiene que ser
continua en los puntos extremos nos
preguntan qué condiciones hace verdadera
la afirmación de jaime
vamos a asegurarnos de que se cumplen
ambas condiciones para poder afirmar que
este enunciado es verdadero la opción a
dice h es continua en el intervalo
cerrado de 3 a 7 esto cumple la segunda
condición pero la continuidad no implica
diferencia habilidad así que esta opción
no nos da la seguridad como para afirmar
que es diferenciable en el intervalo
abierto si algo es diferenciable
entonces también es continuo pero si es
continuo no necesariamente es
diferenciable un ejemplo clásico de esto
sería cuando tenemos una esquina o un
borde puntiagudo ya que no es
diferenciable en ese punto aún cuando
sea continuo ahí descartamos esta
primera opción la opción b dice h es
continua y decreciente en el intervalo
cerrado de 3 a 7 esto tampoco nos ayuda
porque no significa que el intervalo sea
diferenciable puede ser continuo y
después decrementar teniendo una de
estas curvas afiladas en donde no es
diferenciable por lo que descartamos la
opción b la opción se dice h es
diferenciable en el intervalo cerrado de
3 a 7
esta opción suena bien porque si algo es
diferenciable en el intervalo cerrado
también será diferenciable en el
intervalo abierto aunque no incluye los
extremos esto es un subconjunto de esto
de aquí y si es diferenciable en el
intervalo cerrado también será continuo
en el intervalo cerrado la diferencia
habilidad implica continuidad me gusta
esta opción la última opción es el
límite cuando x tiende a 5 de h prima de
x igual a 1 nos dice que el límite de
nuestra derivada conforme x se aproxima
a 5 es igual a 1 no sabemos si esto es
verdadero y aunque el límite fuese
verdadero esto no implica necesariamente
que h prima de 5 sea igual a 1 aún no
sabemos si esto es verdadero este
enunciado no nos asegura que existe un
valor c en el intervalo cuya derivada
sea igual a la tasa de cambio promedio
en ese intervalo descartamos esta opción
y con esto terminamos